shot bakes the head fakes by heart and
you have a chance there Jones jr. trying
the assignment are in the step back
you might want to patent that step back
jumper switch but we ran into Goran
trackage and championship alley tonight
that's the first thing he mentioned to
us that defensively the Rockets which
almost every match on carton buries a
three in transition
as part the familiar tone that start the
game at least recently for the heat eric
three-point shooting at one four five
and a pardon with a clear Lane able to
get past Derek Jones for another scored
I chose with seven on the shot clock
reach in when he swings it by Tony this
one's going to say about Bob them with
Paul in heart and holding the ball most
of the time Martin loves the crossover
he and Paul and spurt handlers another
tripod joining with a lane that wide
open and big men all spread away Bart
Rizal gave him too much space 21 for
James Harden lie on their back court
guys to get it done they just had google
boy no last night they played and you
expect them to be a little tired tonight
they're not you got a Jay rich having a
great third quarter a toe run for the
heat their first lead since he was 7 to
6
forward it didn't last long at all
though 25 points for Hart one-point lead
for Miami halfway through the third
quarter Barton over Josh
what a stroke for James Lee
[Music]
comes baseline oh he's so good get the
champ steps in that first dribble Wow
James Harden 30 points but just three
and six at home hardens three
33 minutes could resume Friday night
against the Bucks those two guys who
only played 36 minutes together in seven
games need one to sit to the South
bargetrip game in a row it's got a hope
that Harden and Paul missed his shots
these guys is so incredible the dead
Jason about
[Applause]
your triple-double he was out there on
this one 41 for James